welcome back to new rock stars moon
knight episode 5 broke all of our hearts
put them on the scales of emotion and
deem them sad my heart is still sad it's
been a couple of days now maybe i should
see someone about this can't anyone be
happy in the mcu why is there so much
sadness why like why can't
steve and vision just be happy why
anyway this is rogue theory the show
where we pitch the wildest theories for
the nerdy titles that we love my name is
mt and growing rogue with me today is
someone who can drive my boat across the
duant anytime it's whitney van leningen
what's going on with me
oh man
i love driving boats baby let's go i
love driving love people
don't fear me
oh
and the only man whose heart i would lay
next to mine on the scales of a noob
it's tommy beck told what's going on
big head gang peaches and cream
so glad to talk about all these topics
for the first time i love a fresh rogue
theory
never to be discussed again
and then poof it's gone forever
yes
it's true though
he's breaking i don't like
[Laughter]
and a man with a card for anything and
everything it's off-screen producer
brandon what's going on hello gang i'm
so happy to be back uh here on rogue
theory again uh yeah i'm so excited to
talk about this episode it's crazy i
love it
more hippo lady and everything that's
what i gotta do yes we need more hippos
in the mcu in general we are a hippo
superhero
everything else it's like some
incredible cgi that hip away it looks
yeah yes
a lot of people before these disney plus
shows started they were like how good is
the cg going to be really for a marvel
disney plush show yeah really good
really good actually really yeah so hats
off to them
wait was it was it a tweet or was or did
somebody post it on on slack i do not
remember but did you guys see that
picture where it's like she has hippo
feet but human hands oh yeah yes johnson
pointed out yeah which
are so
interesting they are so interesting but
i do love that they gave her the cat's
treatment of just a little bit yeah yeah
just anthropomorphic enough to make it
bizarre hey yeah you need uh you need
five fingers to operate a boat i feel
like you do like yeah because like
hippos can't just drive boats if they
have like little clompers you know
and that reminds me today's episode is
brought to you by little clompers
little cloppers oh my god
driving
[Laughter]
but
boats
we should just do this whole episode
with tommy impersonating me
first of all it's a trip
it is a tribute
oh that was the best all right so we're
definitely in the end game now for moon
night with only one episode left in the
series it's time for us to make our
rogue's theories on how this show is
going to wrap things up so that leads us
to our first topic of today how will the
series end cause with mark
stevens stuck in an afterlife not the
afterlife and harrow presumably
achieving his goal in the land of the
living and all those people dying
presumably which is not fun how do we
think the series is going to come to a
conclusion in the final episode will
there be any major ripples across the
mcu and when might we see moon knight
again after the show i think that the
end of this show i'm gonna go very rogue
on this now it's gonna be big okay i
think all of these egyptian gods are
gonna get killed by ahmed i think ahmet
is gonna be released and she's gonna
turn on all these gods and somehow kill
the gods
uh and because she's gonna be pissed
that she was locked away in the first
place by this kangaroo court of gods of
the indians
so she's gonna be released
by arthur harrell maybe he's already
done it that's why those souls are
dropping down but i think she'll turn on
arrow she'll eat harrow she's gonna eat
all the other gods and i think it's
gonna be a complete wipeout of the
egyptian gods
except for
because we need moon knight to keep
existing we need conscience yeah maybe
because it's not a weird thing that like
arthur herrera was saying in like the
earlier episodes that like kanchu was
obsessed with releasing ahmet uh right
it wasn't him like he was he had kind of
uh conscious had set hero on this path
and he was like yeah let's get let's get
ahmed out and like that's conscious
secretly does want ahmet released in a
weird way and maybe because he knows
that like he'll eat all the other gods
and count you hates the other gods
yeah that's my like rogue theory is that
like my enemies
yes yes
[Laughter]
i like that that would be nuts because
like i definitely feel like at the end
of this series we're gonna get a
situation where harrow bites off a
little bit more than he can chew and
like the forces that he's dealing with
are not really in his best interest like
he's going to get sort of like how we
saw with case ilius in doctor strange
one it's like oh yeah you want to be one
with the one it's not going to be what
you like oops you did um so yeah
well kind of like red skull too right
like he wanted the tester exactly and
then when he touched it it's like oh i
didn't want this
no no more legs for you you're floating
forever
no more legs or friends
um sorry red skull but no i can tell
really sad i like my legs and my friends
i like both of those things to have
suddenly ripped away in a moment's
notice over my own greed
over my own degree maybe like maybe he
just really wanted someone to like
sacrifice themselves from to to make the
soul stone so that he could be free so
he could have a penis again we don't
know if he has a picture
we don't know
hello
you don't know that he does it we should
just assume it's still there come on
that's not fair i don't know it's not
fair to my boy
dick the benefit of the doubt why would
i give me proof i need evidence
trust me you're not am i right ronald
reagan 1989 or whatever
i mean i don't want to both sides the
argument but red skull did kill a bunch
of nazis as well so i mean you know this
is a deserve a penis let me imagine him
without one
listen
like a ken doll
he does i mean listen killing nazis is
great but
come on he doesn't siding with them is
not so great fighting with them is not
so you don't really get a pass
uninterested you don't get a pass and
you don't get a penis
exactly no penis or pass no personal
penis that's what i always say no penis
no peace
and then k-n-o-w no penis no no
no people i solemnly swear i'm
[Laughter]
go for it i'm gonna answer your question
in two parts well how do i think
moonlight is gonna end okay
mark spector aka steven aka jake
yeah is gonna
get back into the land of the living
he's gonna get back and he's gonna free
and then he's going to fight emmett and
something's going to happen and all
those little other ushakis that we saw
in the shelves are going to break
and all the egyptian gods are going to
be free and that's going to set up our
next mood night adventure where he has
to go
and recapture all of the
uh i'm going to say heck raising
egyptian gods that are now running amok
hecaries around the world
and who's going to help you christian i
like it and who's going to help him well
my friend that is the next uh disney not
next but an upcoming disney plus
original series announced the d23 this
summer this is my prediction the
midnight suns the midnight
track
i love me some midnight sons tommy and i
do love me a ghostbusters type scenario
where we're just hunting down oh you're
going to talk like oh midnight
midnight
tonight's times will be showing up
kicking down doors show me that dick
pretty much
yeah
wow
what a
what a slogan i don't know if that would
work that's very long for the last
that's going to be on disney plus but
the plus will be turned to an x it'll be
on disney yeah
that's why they just that's why they
instituted parental controls so they
could finally
show me that policy i don't need to
explain it i mean honestly disney needs
like
to
go up a a
rating anyways because it was like this
episode they were like hang on how do we
take bambi's mom dying and like
amplify that for a modern audience yeah
and then they did and then they did they
hold my beard bambi and it was yeah yeah
like
they weren't showing like upsetting
disney parent death i have ever seen
ever it's awful it's so bad they won't
show like graphic physical violence but
man will they show graphic emotional
violence yeah
like that's how they make their money
just making us cry you know
destroying my story remember when those
toys were almost went into the
incinerator
dude they are they are addicted to
making us those sick
they just want us
they just want us
i mean i think they crossed the line
crossing the rubicon was up right they
were like what if we front load this
movie with so much trauma yeah will
people still stay and watch the whole
thing in one musical number in one
little dude
i was like we'll just throw a duck in
there and they play because they play
that song at the parks while you're
walking around you'll just hear that
song and think about your loved one
dying in your arms and you're just like
geez remember when you were at disney
world with your wife edna not anymore
sorry
so yeah no i really do like this
scenario of like all these gods coming
out and like you know possibly maybe
even possessing people and being like
all right i'm just just like taking out
their will all over the world yeah i
like that and then like you know all
these midnight sons have to fight the
gods which is pretty dope and like i
would love if you know your boy hercules
was involved as well because
and he's just fighting
you know what i'm saying
just saying and also we could cast liam
hemsworth because that's the hemsworth
brother that is not doing anything right
now in the mcu
hercules come on anyway
that would be interesting because like
in the comics like hercules and thor
they're always like kind of
uh going against you know the competing
all the time if if they made her gillies
look just like thor too that would be
really funny seriously it would be
hilarious hercules is like a little [ __ ]
like
he really is like in the comics like
that dude is like he's like 10 times
iron man honestly like that dude gets
around well i mean he gets that from his
dad right i suppose
of course
get that from your dad that's like the
most inherited trait of all greek gods
yes
um
[Laughter]
yeah he definitely uh should probably
get himself tested for sure oh he should
oh no
oh hercules a hundred percent will give
you hpv no questions yeah use the rabbit
before you
for sure
[Laughter]
um but wait what you got wendy i think
that it might follow this is this is
like kind of too rogue but i think that
it could
follow the end of the welcome to new
egypt's comic run because
um at the very end of that what happens
is that we see
every possible variant of
like mark specter moon night so we see
jake luckily we see stephen we see like
just other versions of moon knight from
different parts of the
multiverse whatever and they basically
all come together and they decide that
they are going to kill conscious like
once
because he's like the problem and like
all the other gods also hate kanju like
mark hates kanchu for like
messing his whole life up and all this
stuff
and uh i think it would be a really cool
lead-in into the multiverse of madness
because
there's going to be so many variants
then maybe we see that these variants of
mark specter moon knight whoever start
coming through the cracks dr strange dun
and
some [ __ ] up for the world so maybe
someone's gonna they're gonna sneak on
through i think they're gonna get sneaky
and they're gonna kill konchu as a unit
friends i like that yeah i would love
that so much like especially if like
each of those like different variants
could have been like you know if steve
was the host of one body and like you
know jacob yeah
i would love to see different moon
knights teaming up and like just you
know killing can't you why not screw god
cool too i literally just thought of
this but it would be so dope if like the
variants were
the versions of like like steven grant
from the comics so he's like an actor
and like
actually yeah yeah like actually like
that would be so sick i would like yes
like i want the actual comics universe
to cross into the mcu so badly because
like i would get so emotional to see
like actual spider-man teaming up with
spider-man actual moon knight teaming up
yeah like all that it would be so i mean
actually
but like if it was like canonical in the
marvel comics if they say like i'm from
universe 616 people will like yeah just
yeah yeah like
people would lose their minds it would
be like turning on mr bright side at a
white people
we were talking about that before we
shot sorry guys that was a joke from
before
it's for the the cool kid just kidding
i'm not cool anyway um anyway here we go
uh but no i i really like that theory a
lot i think i'll be freaking dope to see
all those moon knights just fighting
together in any type of scenario because
we have the multiverse coming and so
like it would be like if even if like
three if three moon knights teamed up
together that's nine people that's so
cool as a concept that's really
i'm cool it i just want it to happen and
also empty i think that's something that
like you and i like are really the same
on is that both of us just like have
way too much knowledge about the comics
and we're just like no it should work
like this in real life no this is how
it's going to like happen and like
that's so like the angle that both of us
come from in our videos like all the
time where we're just like no this is
from we love the comics man the comics
are where it's at
where all the inspiration comes from i
know the like basically if you look at
the comics that they say these
things are based on it's just a road map
for what we're actually gonna see so
like of course the mcu like throws in
their own [ __ ] puts in their new details
changes stuff around borrows from here
puts that back whatever but like
ultimately it like if you read the
comics you can kind of you can figure it
out you can figure it out you can i'm
pretty sure the road map is there and
like especially now that kevin feige is
now like the head of like the marvel
comics as well like you can expect like
like what's coming out now to possibly
be what's coming in the mcu way further
down the line in the next like 10 years
so like pay attention read the marvel
comics because they're they're
definitely there's really good stuff but
like they're also the basis for what's
to come so i just can't believe that
kevin feige didn't invite any of us to
that retreat like what's going on
seriously kevin let us come to the
retreat i watched i have some really
weird ideas frogman ideas
frogmen for one and for seven um
support frogman and mt man
that's what i'm here for that's all i
want and then i'll leave you with peace
cut
but no oh these were all freaking dope
ass theories but i really really
particularly love the theory this like
ghostbusters scenario from tommy because
like all these gods coming out and then
just possessing people or just causing
just mischief and then blade is like ah
man
i wouldn't i should you shouldn't have
touched those ushabi's mr uh uh mr
spectre like now you have to help us
clean it up just all the way it does in
the mcu is tell people they shouldn't
touch things
don't touch don't do that you're going
to get burned up
[Laughter]
his glasses just lead them to people
that are about to touch things like all
right thank you glasses
but no i really like this theory so i'm
going to give tommy 20 000 rogue points
for that one because that is just i love
me a luigi's mansion a ghostbusters it's
just fun fun times all around but those
these other theories of like amit going
around going crazy and just killing all
the gods i want to see that that'd be
freaking dope because like gore would be
like hey that's a god i like that's my
choice
i totally i was gonna say that but i
didn't want to interrupt brandon when he
was talking but i was just like hmm do
you think that that would make it so
that gore like in love and thunder comes
back and he's like
hey i actually i'm not gonna kill you
because you would help me take
[Laughter]
would you like to get married ahmet
would you like to get married yeah no
honestly just like hey like we're doing
the same kind of thing and it's been
hard for me to find a good woman so
but i also of course do love this theory
of these multiverse marks as well coming
in and just running just just beating
conscious up and uh just uh even though
i do love conscious because he's a sassy
man but he's a jerk so he did take
advantage of mark so he doesn't need a
beating so i do like that scenario where
they just say [ __ ] you and um
and just beat this man in the second
verse of markness
yes multiverse of marcus let's get it
let's go so i'm gonna give both of you
eighteen thousand rules ah
slight lead
[Music]
so tommy is in the lead so but it's
still anyone's game but up next we are
going to talk about the possible powers
of one doctor tarot but first starting
this coming monday new rockstars will be
launching a brand new daily show that
will be streaming live every weekday
afternoon right here on the youtube.com
have you heard of it it's pretty popular
this show is called the break room and
will feature lots of familiar faces from
this channel and we'll be talking about
nerd news sharing theories lots of
theories breaking down videos and
interacting with all of you which is the
best part of doing a live show be sure
to check out the break room starting
monday may 2nd right here on the new
rockstars youtube channel and also new
rockstars is now on tumblr which is also
another popular site which you've heard
of not not it's not a startup so if
you're a current tumblr user a former
user who probably needs to reset their
password or new to the platform
altogether come check out what we are
doing on our official new rockstars
tumblr page and what makes it even
better is that our own jessica clemens
is there right now possibly posting all
of her crazy theories which are amazing
so be sure to check it out right now and
just you know join on tumblr it's really
good and we also want to thank upstart
because it can be hard to see the light
at the end of the tunnel when you have a
high interest debt and sometimes it can
be even harder to ask for help and
that's where upstart comes in upstart
powered personal loans help you pay down
high interest debt all online with
simple to understand payment terms and
upstart has helped over 1.8 million
customers on their path to financial
freedom so whether it's paying off
credit cards consolidating high interest
debt or funding personal expenses
upstart can help you get one fixed
monthly payment with a clear payoff date
so upstart knows that you are more than
just your credit score upstart's model
considers other factors like your income
employment and other information
provided in your loan application to
find you a smarter rate for your loan
you can check your rate in minutes for
loans between one thousand to fifty
thousand dollars without impacting your
credit score and you can even receive
funds as fast as one business day after
accepting your loan so do not wait to
check out your rate today at upstart.com
rogue theory that is upstart.com rogue
theory to check your rates today and
don't forget to use our url to let them
know that we sent you loan amounts will
be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application go to
upstart.com
rogue theory all right gang because the
moonlight series has played around with
what's really happening and what's
merely an illusion in someone's mind
clearly because uh
what's going on i don't know and it's
not the
and it's the not knowing what's real
that leaves the audience wondering what
to trust so that leads us to our second
topic for today does harrow have any
real agency in this psychiatric ward so
like is this dr harrow we see
interacting with mark and steven in the
psychiatric ward purely a manifestation
of mark and stephen or does the hero in
the real world have some insight into
what is happening in the land of the
dead what do you guys think oh i've got
one for this my friend
right away tommy i've come equipped with
a few theories in my
like that big head today that sounds
weird i'm sorry yes this big head
has lots of theories in it
some that can't be shared on the
internet no here's my theory
i believe harrow has his agency in
the mind and and after life and after of
mark spector
uh or stephen because my theory is that
if you have been an avatar of conscious
and if we believe that that arthur was
once conscious avatar i consider it i
liken it to kind of how in stranger
things like if you've been to the upside
down the upside down then becomes a part
of you we've got will puking up little
slugs having flashbacks in the arcade
seeing the upside down in the in the
regular world i think once you you are
everyone has a bond a conscious
connection if you will once you become
an avatar so my theory is arthur is able
to exist in that world because he was
also an avatar of conscious so he
therefore has a uh psychic link
with mark
and i rest my case
really dig this idea a lot because like
it's very much avatar the last airbender
where it's like there's this connection
between everybody that has had a
connection to kanchu and like it's it
just it does make sense it doesn't make
sense considering that tuareg said that
this realm was untethered consciousness
so like this is a realm where like all
potentially all the consciousnesses that
were connected to kanju could be you
know able to meet up and talk so like i
love this theory a lot it just makes a
lot of sense that's where hot singles
meet up and talk in mark specter
the consue connection
[Laughter]
they all got a lot of kids um anyway
show me your pee
what else you guys got
i think that hero has to have
it can't just be a a manifestation of
like marx or steven's like
idea of hero i think it's got he's got
to have some control there because he
does seem like he's guiding it in a
certain way or like trying to convince
mark that he's crazy and none of it is
real
like
to keep mark and stephen locked away i
guess are stuck in the underworld
because i think that harrow i still
think that harrow is anubis
uh in some weird way and then like i
would give him a lot of power in like
the underworld and like it's just the
idea that he seems like too much to be
just a normal person who was once an
avatar like something so shady going on
him and like osiris having their little
weird dealings i think like he's somehow
like the only egyptian god that can
physically be on earth
maybe because of his connections with
the underworld or whatever he made a
deal with the devil mephisto i don't
know but like uh he's somehow able to be
there and because of his like you know
his underworld powers he is like able to
interact with mark
steven who's like stuck in the
underworld because i that that one scene
where they came back and you know right
at the beginning of the episode and
mark's all like beat up and that was
like we never see him beat up like that
again and we hadn't seen him like that
before he got like the broken nose and
stuff they inject him with piss into his
neck like that was some weirdness that i
think means something good all urine
injection to calm you down that's such a
weird
i mean there's some some wacky
conspiracy theorists out there injecting
themselves with piss right now to
prevent coven it doesn't work don't do
it
don't do it i say go for it at this
point
it's bad you know what if you're at a
point where you want to inject piss in
yourself who am i to say no don't let me
know
who am i to spoil the party don't let
anyone say congratulations you're
[Laughter]
um but no like this hero as anubis is
freaking
weird and cool
there's more than meets the eye to hero
and it there's got to be something
i would love if like arthur harold like
did an animorph just like i am actually
a newbie
into
dog and then we just watch like
and
a
literally the animorphs like secrets
just happen seriously like it has to be
90s like
like terrible for no reason yes yeah
that would be hilarious but no i love
this idea of like that harry was
actually a god who's like all right i
want to release like my ex-girlfriend or
something it's like all right i like i
love ahmet so like we i just wanted to
be together and we would just kill
she'll kill people and then more people
for me in the underworld and stuff so
like yeah perfect match to made in
heaven i like it it's a cool idea i
really like that that is very cool
because it's like yeah of course he
would want more souls yeah
he's lonely yeah why wouldn't
he sing
in your
area single souls in your area
um but no what you got wendy okay so my
theory is
intense but okay hear me out so i think
that
harrow does have complete agency within
the mind of moon knight um because he
still has access to the body right so
like he has access to the body on the
outside and i think that that means that
he's probably able to do some kind of
voodoo situation with it
you know just he's just sticking pins in
the little voodoo doll
and um
so i think that that's how he's able to
do it and i think that
um
that place really is like the purgatory
where they are trapped between like life
and death and then
both uh mark and stephen mark gets
trapped in the field of reeds he it's
great but he does not want to be there
at all he wants to go back go back into
his ex-wife obviously is a better choice
than being dead and then stephen is like
frozen in sand glass
situation
down in the uh the sands of the
underworld and the dead he does that guy
does use
lotion get on it dude moisturized
um
and so i think that that leaves the
possibility that
uh mark's third identity jake lockley is
still
in the purgatory area because i think
that
he was the person
in the second sarcophagus because
stephen woke up in his own sarcophagus
and then we saw that sarcophagus like
shaking and rattling around and at the
end of episode four it seems that in
that world each person gets their own
body in the afterlife and so mark has
his own body steven has his own body so
logically we could assume that jake
lockley will have his own body in that
world and so i think that what happened
was when mark escaped found stephen and
then the two of them went to hippotown
um i think that jake lockley
busted out of his coffin tipped it over
because it was it was standing upright
right so like and coffins are really
heavy by the way i looked this up
because i was like how heavy is it to
push a lid off a coffin dude coffin lids
can be anywhere from 300 pounds to 3
tons
not a joke they can be anywhere on that
scale of heaviness so like yeah it makes
sense that little steven
couldn't like push it up push it off
because yeah because that's just like
doing the world's most extreme
weightlifting situation um
so it would have been easier for upright
coffin to just tip itself over fall out
like that
jake could have popped out and then when
uh harrow's guards were roaming the
hospital halls looking for mark they
found jake instead and because jake is
the most violent of the three personas
jake probably fought back against the
guards which is why he got beat up and
then that would be jake lockley in that
scene where his face is all messed up
because yeah like like brandon said we
never see his face messed up again you
know like that's the only time so i
think that that is the
jake's body and jake's persona in that
scene and that harrow still has access
to jake lockley's soul because he's
still in that purgatory area
mark is in the good place steven's in
the bad place and i think that jake is
gonna be the key to pulling them out of
the afterlife because he's basically
like their man on the outside
i like that makes so much sense because
like he there was still that jake
personality in that coffin whoever is in
that coffin can come out at any time and
to be like all right um there's still we
still got a shot in the game here comes
player three
yeah player three has entered the chat
yeah did i miss
spaghetti night
and then like all those all those times
that we were seeing um what we thought
was mark could actually have been jake
like i love that idea we're like we we
sort of like like jumped forward in time
a bit for to like after uh like steve it
was already in the sand and mark was
already in read heaven like it would it
just makes sense for for that to happen
i really want jake to be the one that
saves the day it'd be really cool
fight at the end he gets left out like
she was measuring their two hearts and
it's like hey what about this third guy
where's his heart
what about jake i have a he killed a few
people who cares come on what i mean
it's totally fine like i have a weird
theory of my own when it comes to um to
jake and steven um because like if you
notice this is like a weird
kind of like my weird marvel trigger
theory color theory so please bear with
me um so like if you notice like the the
color of steven's coffin was like gold
when he came out and the color of this
crazy coffin is red like chaos energy so
like i think that steven represents like
the good soul part and like this jake is
like more chaotic he's like all right
i'm like this is like pure like chaos so
this is the chaos in me that like um the
hero was talking about like this is like
i'm ready to fight like i'm ready to
like throw hands so like this is like
different like so like the the i don't
know the the wholesome and the chaos
sort of balance themselves out leaving
um mark to be
like all right as long as i understand
myself then everyone thinks balance
um so like it's like i don't know that's
just my weird theory there but anyway
i don't know why i just went into that
uh
it's beautiful no it's great but no i
loved all three of these i say it all
the time but like i love all three of
these theories um again like this jake
being the one that saves the day i think
that's highly likely and i think that's
something that could be very like real
really cool to see it in episode six um
as we just get to know jake a little bit
before season two potentially um so yeah
i'm gonna give whitney 30 000 points for
that one because that was
crazy and amazing um and but i really of
course
love the konshu connection because
someday we'll find it the kanji
connection
um frog man let's get it um but yeah so
i think that you know i i should give
tommy 28 000 points oh my gosh because
good god um that's pretty cool i like i
think that i want to see every single
avatar at one point and like maybe even
giving them advice like like all right
this is how you really moon night did
you know that you had like um really
cool battle rings if you if you pulled
it out of your butt i don't know i don't
know why but um you never try the butt
there's all neat stuff in the butt if
you pull out yeah marvel
marvel needs to just
just give us more butt stuff i need
[Laughter]
but i also do want to see an anamorph
type scenario with uh with arrow with
his cane to be like oh check this check
out what my cane can do oh but i'm a dog
now um so like it'd be really cool to
see like a really cool like showdown
between like a dog anubis and
and uh moon night would be dope um so
i'm gonna give you
27 000 points oh geez
i'm sorry i'm sorry
i don't watch me the points don't mean
anything these are all great theories uh
but no we are now going to go to our
rogue question because now it's that
time of the show i don't know if you
guys knew how the show works but that's
just how it works now
filming has recently begun on the latest
fast and the furious sequel fast x is an
indie film it's an indie franchise i
hope it's gonna be well uh it's gonna
take off really soon but however it has
been announced this week that director
justin lin would no longer be directing
the film and is amicably stepping away
over creative differences so this means
that the film needs a new director so i
need you guys to give me your rogus
choice for a new director and describe
what new signature flair that they could
bring to the project well here's here's
where we're gonna go we're gonna go way
off of where they've been heading with
this this go rogue brother we're gonna
bring in uh wes anderson with his
signature style
same cast everyone's still there
uh but this this is gonna be like a
prequel of extreme prequel set in the
1950s
uh during the monte carlo grand prix
all of our characters are coming back
with diesel's there
uh you know uh ludicrous is there
hell and mirror
hillary and ludacris at the monte carlo
grand prix they've got very twee outfits
right and you know alec baldwin's
narrating the whole thing and every card
she's seen is like stop motion with like
little toy cars uh and the title of the
film is going to be the fascinating tale
of the speedy and aggrieved uh and
that's right
the fascinating tale of the wes
anderson's take on the fast
oh my god you know what i i need to see
this immediately i think it's hilarious
i think shake the core of the franchise
like but for no reason we should just
have those like really like sexy girls
that like hold up to like the the ghost
side for no reason like just added
like completely out of the era
yeah we'll do one
anachronistic thing there and then it'll
be the race it's like all right this is
just fast and furious signature this is
what we do with the series
but that'd be hilarious i mean i would
love to see that what do you guys got i
also want to take it in a radically
different direction i go radical go
radical i would love to see lars uh lars
von trier take over this franchise and
and add
full
uh realistic sex scenes
to
the fastest oh my god
oh no that's the furious babies really
do be loving them cars man yeah well i
mean i i guess i hadn't thought that the
people would be having sex with the cars
i i just thought oh they have to they
have to yeah and bro
and like it's just natural because
diesel always goes inside of the vehicle
time to fill you up with diesel fuel
should be like married he has like a
wife he has kids but that car is out and
driving yeah that car oh yeah
outside of the boys flashes the
headlights adam and he's like yeah yeah
yeah i gotta be strong wow um honey
where are you going type of striking
vipers we're gonna eat dinner he's like
i gotta go for a drive babe don't ask
sometimes a man just keeps down
[Laughter]
um in but the asses
in cinemas
this is very extreme um
and the z is like a weird little like uh
what do you call it like a tire skid
yeah yeah yeah
you got it
you got it you're there
i love it but what you got with me okay
i'm going to i'm going to give a serious
answer because i have thought about this
a lot i have thought about who should
direct the fast and the furious every
second of the last few days um so
i
would like to pitch freddie wong as
director of freddie wow the man himself
i want to see fast and the furious
rocket jump dungeons and daddy's style
that's what i'm here for
i would like i really genuinely think
that he could kill it i just i love his
creative ideas uh i listened to talking
dads which is the dungeons and daddies
after show that the whole crew does
together and freddy really just like
understands film in a way that i'm like
i'm like damn he could genuinely
genuinely make the fast and the furious
amazing i just think he could i think it
would be a great
version of that film series
so i'm gonna vote freddie wong
bro if you i don't know if you've ever
seen like that freddie wong skit with a
key and peel but like it's one of the
coolest funniest things ever yes and
like i was a huge fan of a video game
high school way back in the day i went
way back in the day and like
such a interesting and talented dude
like so good so like i love that idea so
much because he would kill it he would
kill it he would kill him he would
so bad like so good actually bad in a
good way like he did back in the day i'm
bad i'm bad copyright strike i'm sorry
all right here we go but yeah no i love
that idea so much and all of these ideas
but you know i do love my boy freddie
wong a whole lot a whole lot i do love
him a lot so i'm gonna have to give
whitney
100 thousand points
what can i say he would really make like
the whole franchise especially if
they're going into space apparently i
haven't seen fast nine yeah but if
they're going to space freddie wong can
really bring it um with the wacky ideas
so like absolutely freddie wong call him
up seriously right now
let him do it
seriously but um i think that i've never
awarded points that high so i would say
that whitney is our winner
good job that's fair that's fair
um she is the amazing scarlet witch and
uh she just
she used her scarlet witch magic to to
make her the winner because i've never
watched reality and now i've won
probably one of the millions who knows
the points don't matter these are all
amazing theories you guys are all super
smart people so you guys all should be
feel proud of yourselves but this is
that but that is it for this episode of
rogue theory thank you to our amazing
guests whitney van lenningham tommy
bechtold and brandon barrack support all
of them on you know twitter with and
everything that they do because they're
amazing people like super amazing and um
you can support our channel by checking
out all of our amazing merch over at new
rockstarsmerch.com and check out our
official tumblr page run by the amazing
jessica clemons you know her you love
her so head on over to our tumblr so you
can interact with jess because she loves
you and tune in monday for our new daily
live show the break room right here on
our youtube channel because we have the
funniest people working for us and you
have to hang out with us because we're
going to talk about some wildlife get
wild so tune in and also you can share
your rogue theories over at our discord
if you are over 18 click the link in the
description box below to describe to
join our discord server today and of
course you can follow me at
mastertainment on twitter see me tweet
some really weird [ __ ] and insane
theories and of course you can follow
new rockstars and all our social media
platforms and thank you guys so much for
watching again we love you guys times a
million bajillion and we'll see you guys
next time goodbye
[Music]
you